we are preparing for the video
conference tomorrow president putin and
president biden will be having a talk
this is a very complicated moment for
the talks the rhetoric coming from the
us and eu leaders sounds pretty
aggressive we see plenty of fake news
about russia allegedly planning an
aggressive invasion at the same time no
one talks to kiev no one warns kiev
against even thinking of a military
intervention in the donetsk and lugans
conflict and given the complicated
background of u.s russian relations it
will be a difficult talk for the leaders
now we see that nato demonstrates its
extremely aggressive position we see mr
stoltenberg's rhetoric we see the
different u.s leaders rhetoric first
they all say that they don't accept any
red lions second they say that nato will
do whatever it wants
third it will do it on whatever
territory it wants
fourth all of this is aimed to deter
russia we don't like that we do
everything to ensure our own interests
under previous administrations when at
least something constructive remained in
our relations our countries had reached
an agreement to establish a secure video
call line for the highest level contacts
it had been abandoned until now although
its technical working order had been
maintained but now i think since
everyone has been using the video cool
format for the past two years we decided
to revive this line especially since it
allows us to discuss the most
secret topics